Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary and in the
divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep, and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires, and may you my beloved divine will
do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so
intimately that I may never swerve from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that
I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of
resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Home divine will with all the angels and saints,
especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit,
and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. We want to begin with September the 5th 1926 this evening, and the Lord is going to
talk to us about the vast paternity that we have in the divine will. Carissa said, I was feeling
oppressed or rather as though lifeless because of the privation of my sweet Jesus. We have said
often that Louisa is literally living a miraculous life. So if Jesus appears to withdraw from her
all her ability to survive actually withdraws as well, because he is the one sustaining her
physically, mentally, emotionally, and spiritually. This pain is always new, she said, and evermore
piercing in such a way as to form new wounds and to make my poor soul bleed with pain. Now,
to have your body bleeding with pain is bad enough to have your soul bleeding with pain is
something that many of us may not have any experience of. Soul pain is beyond description. It's an
awful lot worse than heart-rending. Only someone who has experienced soul pain could have any idea
of how terrifying it actually is. Now, while I was in this nightmare, that's why she would call
it a nightmare, of the pain of his privation, my beloved Jesus moved in my interior. That's because
the Kingdom of God is within you, Luke 1721. And one Corinthians 3 16, no you not that you are the
temple of the living God and that the spirit of God dwells in you. So he moved in my interior,
clasping me to his most holy heart. I've always said he's very good at the hugs, telling me my
daughter, look at the titles he's going to give her. Our daughter, that's the daughter of the most
holy Trinity, the daughter of our celestial mother, the daughter of the angels, the daughter of the
saints, the daughter of the heavens, the daughter of the sun, the daughter of the stars, the daughter
of the sea, in some you are the daughter of all. So she's the daughter of everyone who's in the
divine will. Notice that in the Kingdom of the divine will there is absolute unity and all are
for one and one is for all. All of them are fathers to you. Now the word father in English means your
origin or where you actually come from. And so we have actually come from the divine will and when
we go back into the divine will, we're going back into our origin. And so all others who are in the
divine will, they all participate in giving us life. How long is your daughter ship, he said,
instead of oppressing yourself, you should delight. Now she's in desperate pain. So, you know, he's
asking a lot. But since her daughter ship is so great, I want to give you again Romans 819 because
it's these sons or daughters of God that the whole of the world as well as the whole of humanity will
be restored. So instead of oppressing yourself, you should delight thinking that all our fathers
to you, you are the daughter of all. But of course, if you're in this vast terrible soul pain, you're
not able to think like that. The only thing that is in your consciousness is this shocking pain.
Only one who lives in my will can have the right to such a vast paternity. Now he's giving us a lot
of reasons in volume 19 to really get into divine will if we have hesitated. Only one who lives in
my will can have the right, notice the word right to such a vast paternity and such a long daughter
ship to be loved by all with paternal love. Now to be loved by the father, to be loved by the
son, to be loved by the spirit, to be loved by the mother of humanity, to be loved by all the saints,
to be personally loved by all the angels. It really is incredible. But he's also saying to be loved by
all the parts of creation as well. Now we're living at a time of great distress where the world is
actually in rebellion against the human being because we are in rebellion as a society. We are
in rebellion against the will of God, but someone who has come right into the will of God, everything
is restored. And so they all come to give life and fellowship to this person because they all
recognize in her their daughter. The thing they all have in common is the divine will raining in them.
In fact, such created things are all invested with my will, which he has told us over and over again.
So wherever the divine will reigns as triumphant and dominating, in other words, it has a true reign,
they see in you the same will that reigns in them, and therefore all hold you as the daughter of their
wombs. It's this recognition. We've noticed this among ourselves as well, that people living or
trying to live in the divine will, there is an immediate recognition of who's who. We actually
recognize one another, even if we don't know the person's name or what country they come from,
it doesn't seem to matter because this is way above that, this wonderful reality. And so there
is this inner recognition of all those who live in the divine will. There are so many bonds between
you and them as to surpass in an infinite way. Notice the word infinite, the natural bonds that
exist between father and son. So this is a bonding that we begin to recognize, but we have got to go
deeper and deeper into its reality so that we can benefit from it. Do you know who is not your
father, only those who do not let my will reign in them? And you can recognize them very easily,
unfortunately. These have no right over you, nor do you have any duty towards them. They are like
something that doesn't belong to you. I find that absolutely amazing that that statement is made
there that Louisa has no duty to anybody outside of the divine will. The mission that was given to her
was to be the head of the mission to the divine will. So she was only told that those within the
divine will would come under her umbrella. Having said that, all prayers in the divine will are for
absolutely everyone. They are universal because divine love doesn't have borders. Divine life
doesn't have borders. And so with the vast number of people who are in fact outside of the divine
will, they are covered completely by the intercessions and prayers of those in the divine will. But
Louisa was told they particularly were not her concern. We were the ones who would try and live
in the divine will that she had to sort of make a way for us. But do you know what it means to
possess such a vast paternity, Jesus said, as such a long daughtership. It means to be bound with
bonds of justice to all the riches, glory, honor, and privileges that such a vast paternity possessors.
Notice bonds of justice. In other words, if you truly are united with the divine will and if the
divine will is really raining in you and having its dominating power working in you and through you,
that you have a right to all of this because that is for everyone and everything in the divine will.
So as my daughter, your Jesus gives you all the goods of redemption as gifts. Now, if you have
your own book in front of you, begin listing these out. That's really incredible what he says.
So as my daughter, we would say my special daughter, because you're in the divine will,
your Jesus gives you all the goods of redemption. Now, people who are not in the divine will are
not capable of reaching out for all the goods of redemption. They may in fact take very little.
I mean, think of someone who waits almost to their deathbed to even take the most basic thing
as forgiveness to enter and reenter into that relationship. Now, for someone to receive all
the goods of redemption, it's absolutely astonishing because only our blessed mother was able to do
that before because of her position in grace and in the divine will. As our daughter, that's the
daughter of the blessed Trinity, you are endowed with all the goods of the most holy Trinity. Now,
all you can do with that is take it off the page, write it down and say, Lord, open my mind to understand
this, open my heart to Graspard. As a daughter or a son of the most holy Trinity, you are endowed
with all the goods. And you know, we've been told in all the passages coming up to this particular
passage that when the most holy Trinity gives, all he and they can give is what they have,
who they are. And that's all of the divine attributes poured into us in so far as we can take them.
As daughter of the sovereign queen, she gives you her sorrows, her works, her love and all her
maternal merits as gifts. Now notice he puts sorrows first. Louisa is the head of a mission and therefore
she has to bear the sorrows of that mission. Our blessed mother was the mother of all humanity.
She had to bear all the sorrows that went with her position. Jesus as the Redeemer had to bear
all the sorrows of humanity as well. And you might be surprised that that is the first thing that is
offered and also her works, her love and all of her maternal merits. As daughter of the angels and
of the saints, they compete among themselves to give you all of their goods. As daughter of the
heavens, the stars, the sun and the sea and all creation things, they feel honored to finally have
their daughter and to be able to give their inheritance. That's why it's so important to do
the rounds so that you are actually including all the different aspects of creation. I always
say that the rounds are really my signature on each part of creation and each part of redemption
and sanctification so that the Lord knows that my signature is there as well. Saying yes and
claiming everything for everyone. So and my very will reigning in the angels and the saints with
its endless light forms for you the deed of all creation and all feel the happiness, the joy of
being able to give their inheritance because by being able to give they no longer feel sterile.
Now notice in all that Jesus says about the Most Holy Trinity, he keeps on saying they want to
give they want to give they want to give. Now you look at the world today and it's in exactly the
opposite direction it wants to take it wants to take it wants to take and the sign of someone who
has really turned to God and to love and to life is that you begin to give and give and give and
you'll notice this in the saints as well. So he's saying that when a person comes deeply enough into
the divine will it is an incredible joy for the angels and saints to be able to give to us and so
they no longer feel sterile but they feel fertile with the fecundity that brings joy and company and
harmony and glory and the repetition of one's very life. But of course God intended us all
to be in his divine will from the very beginning from the time of Adam. He intended us to experience
all that he wanted to give to us and so when the angels and the saints are allowed to share that
it's the abundance that they are experiencing they want to share with us and so the angels and
the saints want us to succeed in reaching the goal much more than I think we ourselves do.
How many fathers and mothers are unhappy even though they are rich because they've no offspring,
they've nobody to give everything to. In fact, sterility in itself brings isolation and bitterness
and lack of any support or of happiness and if it may appear that they enjoy in their hearts there
is the thorn of sterility that embitters all of their enjoyments. Unfortunately society can degenerate
to the point where they actually cultivate sterility which is what's happening today. It's a very
great deterioration of humanity. So your vast paternity which you possess and your long
daughtership is a cause of joy for all because all of these groups and all of these persons are
all pouring out upon you. At much more for my will which by locating in you reigns in you I mean
look at that wonderful statement that the divine will is reigning in heaven and reaches a point
where it can also reign in this little nothing on the earth as well but it's an incredible
victory for the Lord to reign in this little nothing because this little nothing has to hand
over its will in order for that reign to happen. In heaven he has already conquered everything.
It is on the earth that he is in the process of conquering so it's the most wonderful thing
that the divine will reigning in heaven would reign completely and totally in me as well.
And much more from my will which by locating reigns in you and constitutes you the daughter
of all the things created by it. Notice it gives you ownership of the creation in such a way
that all feel your support and the contentment of being able to give the goods that they possess.
Therefore Jesus says to her your oppression is not justified in the midst of so many goods.
Now if Louisa was on the other side outside of the flesh in the spirit of course this would
make a normal sense but since she is absolutely crippled with pain it's interesting the way Jesus
is speaking. But he's telling us that we need to begin to try and appreciate spiritual realities
instead of just staying with material realities around us. Therefore your oppression is not
justified in the midst of so many goods of so much happiness and of so many who protect you,
defend you and love you. Now look at that the most blessed Trinity our blessed mother all the angels
and the saints are each protecting us, defending us and loving us as their true sons and daughters.
All of us trying to live in the divine will. Yes absolutely fantastic. So Louisa goes on.
After this she said I abandoned myself in the arms of Jesus and in the current of the divine
will to do my usual acts. I love the way she can go from a complete crisis to Jesus revealing
something to her and then she gets on with her business of what she should do in praying and
interceding anyway. She's able to move very quickly from one to the other which tells you she's a
very free soul. She's very detached. She's not clinging onto anything. Now she's not even thinking
to her pain or the need that it creates. So she abandons herself in the arms of Jesus and that's
exactly what we need to do in every circumstance of our lives. We must trust him beyond reason and
as time goes on and things get worse in the earth and the antichrist manifests on the earth which
she will do in a short time. We have to trust God beyond reason and throw ourselves in the arms of
Jesus as Louisa is doing here. Everything will be fine. Everything will be fine. And Jesus said to
her my daughter my will preserves the soul in her origin. So going back into the divine will we're
going back into our origin to that relationship that the human race had before the fall. And it
does not allow her to go out of her beginning which is God. Now there's a certain point at which
our commitment in the divine will is permanent. Only you and God know that moment and so you are
brought back to your origin and you are not allowed to go out of it. Remember Louisa has often
described herself as going into this vast sea of light and there's no way out of it. There's
no way you could measure the extent of it or anything else. You are there in this presence
which is God because God is light one John one five. So once we reach this point he won't let you go
back. He protects you from your own weaknesses. The divine will maintains intact the divine image
in the depth of her being. Now the divine image was given to us in Genesis 1 27 Genesis 2 7 and
Paul tells us in Romans 8 29 that we are to be the image of the son. So coming back into our
origin back into this original relationship with God we have to come back into this image that God
created of himself and he will maintain that divine image intact once we are permanently in that
position. We're not moving in and out of the divine will. So it maintains the divine image intact in
the depths of our being which is enclosed in her intellect memory and will. Now the hardest bit
to get shifting is the will but the intellect has to be fed and we have come across this in the
whole nineteen volumes that we have looked at that the intellect must continuously be fed with this
revelation that the Lord is giving so that it will gradually come round and be completely convinced
that the only thing to do not just the right thing but the only thing to do is to surrender
to the divine will and to let the divine will take over and so the intellect absolutely must be fed
and we're used to Louisa saying to us you know he told me something through a light that means
infused knowledge and so we must let the Lord do that with us as well because he's not a respecter
of persons. So this image is enclosed in her intellect memory and will and as long as the soul
allows my divine will to reign in her everything is linked everything is in relationship between
the creator and the creature everything depends on that connection between our will and the divine
will. Even more she lives in the reflections of the supreme majesty and our likeness in her grows
continuously. Read St Paul's letter to the Ephesians chapter 1 verses 11 to 14. So we have to grow
more and more and more in the likeness of Christ. So I keep saying to you as we go through these
volumes that we are given moments at which we can recognize whether we have moved because this is
one of these moments maybe I should call them discernment moments because we ourselves have to
recognize at what point I have moved beyond the point of no return. There's a very important moment
in a flight it's the point of no return you must continue there's absolutely no way you can go back
and there's a point of no return in our giftedness to the divine will as well and it's when you shift
beyond that everything comes into position everything falls into place everything makes sense
and you will know because you will realize if you look back I'm different to what I was last year
I'm not the same I don't think the same I I don't respond the same way the Lord has a much greater
hold on me he's sent her he's there all the time I don't even have to decide to get into the presence
of God it's there all the time and I'm conscious of him and conscious of the fact that he is moving
and he is doing whatever he wants to do these are just discernment moments for you that I like to
give you so even more she lives in the reflections of the supreme majesty and our likeness in her
grows continuously therefore that presence has got to be recognized and this makes her be distinguished
as our daughter on the other hand the human will causes her to deny her origin it makes her decay
from her beginning her intellect memory and will remain without light and the divine image remains
deformed and unrecognizable so here we are going downhill as fast as we can now the human will
breaks all the divine bonds and relationships and therefore it makes the soul live in the reflections
of all the passions so if you find yourself descending into the passions then you you're really in the
wrong direction in such a way that she becomes ugly and she becomes the daughter of the infernal
enemy who tries to engrave his ugly image in her how many evils does ones will not cause it devastates
every good and produces all evils now you're being told to absolutes here one is the sheer glory of
being transformed in God and the other one is the terrifying possibility of being deformed in Satan's
image and so when he gives us these comparisons it really helps us to shift so Jesus is now going
to give us a picture of what he has just said because he knows that we will get something better
if it's illustrated than if it's just given with intellectual information so after this blessed
Jesus brought me outside of myself showed me how deformed his image had become in creatures you're
talking about 1926 it's almost 100 years ago things are infinitely worse now it was horrifying
to see it so unrecognizable and ugly now Jesus has pointed out that if we move away from his image
we actually do become ugly spiritually the sanctity of the gaze of Jesus was reluctant to look at them
that's heppercut 113 lord your gaze is too holy to look upon sin but the compassion of his most
holy heart pushed him to have pity on the works of his hands deformed into being so ugly of because
of their own fault at their own decision and while Jesus was grieved this summit in seeing his image
deformed in this way my book says transformed and that's a wrong use of that word transformed it
should be deformed and seeing his image so deformed we arrived at someplace in which the
offenses which were given to him were so many that unable to take any more he changed his appearance
of goodness assuming the aspect of justice now he has to go onto the justice side i've told you
many times that like children we live between two limits a child lives between the hugs and the
affirmation of the parent and the discipline of the parent and if the child keeps on going towards
the discipline of the parent the child who will experience the parent is very severe but the child
who cooperates and can learn and can obey the parent will only experience the hugs and the
affirmation and so you can have two children in one family who think the parents were completely
different and it's the same in society people who obey the law don't ever come up against the
severity of the law but those who rebel against the law know about courts and prisons and arrests
and all the rest of it and it's the same in our relationship with god we can live
surrendered to him and only know his mercy and love like saint the rays of lisio
and there are others who only seem to know the severity of god because they've moved in the wrong
direction and it's very important for us to just use these images because people can misunderstand
when they see the severity of god there has to be limits there has to be parameters
and so when humanity moves in this direction of being deformed and so unlike anything that has
to do with god chastisement is the only thing that can happen to try and put some correction into
the system to see if some souls can be saved otherwise they'll all be lost and that's a tragedy
you don't want to even consider so he threatened chastisements and earthquakes water and fire
were put out against the people to destroy abandoned cities well that's happening all around us this
is everyday news i prayed him to spare the people and jesus taking me back into bed shared his pains
with me in other words helped her to go into reparation to try and save souls okay let's come to
september the seventh nineteen twenty six and here we learn why it is that the human will is so
important because we're told here that the human will is a spark made from the tip of the rays of
the supreme volition in other words the human will was made as a spark from god and so he cannot bear
to have that spark absolutely destroyed and deformed because if the human will is in its right place
in its relationship with god that human person will experience only wonder and glory and love
which is divine infinite eternal so louisa said i was about to resume my flight in the supreme
volition to make my usual visit in the kingdom of the divine will and to extend myself within its
boundaries in order to let my i love you my adoration my thank you echo for each creation thing i call
that putting your name and your signature on absolutely everything that god created now as i was about
to do this i thought to myself if god is everywhere the sam won three nine where can i go from your
spirit where can i flee from your face if i go to the heavens you are there if i go into the depths
of the darkness even darkness is not dark to you the night is as bright as the day i've just given
you a few tiny bits from it nice long sound it's good one to read so if god is everywhere why do i
have to take flight in the divine volition and to go up to the height of the heavens before the supreme
majesty as though carrying all human wills of the generations on my little lap to do my act of
subjection love and abandonment for each rebellious will so if he's everywhere why do i have to take
this flight into the presence of god in order to conquer the divine will to come and reign upon the
earth dominating and triumphant in the mister creatures now since the divine will is everywhere
i can do it from here now that's not louise's problem i've told you this over and over again
when louise it goes into a thing like this she's actually voicing our problems our difficulties
the way we would think she doesn't need this at all and the lord has told her that he puts
these ideas into her head so that he can give her the answer for us because if you actually had
this problem today who would you turn to who is there to help us there is nobody the church is in
crisis okay so the lord put the question into her so that he could provide the answer before we ever
ask the question so why can't i do it from here so when i was thinking of this my sweet jesus
moving in my interior told me my daughter look at the sun it's light descends and fills the whole
earth but the sun remains always up there 39 000 million miles away under the vault of the heavens
with all majesty in its sphere lording and dominating over everyone and everything with
its light in other words the sun does its wonderful work because it stays in the position that god
put it into the absolute correct position for us but even though it doesn't descend down below
it gives the same effects it communicates the same goods by means of its rays as if
it itself would descend from the height of its sphere more so because if the sun descended watch
this now he's actually saying a lot that's going to come up after this if the sun actually did descend
it would ignite the earth the sun would be a devouring fire if it came too close to the earth
the scientists are always looking at the flares of the sun in case any of them came too close
to the earth because they can do devastation on the earth so the sun is at maximum benefit for us
if it keeps its distance or as jesus would say here it's height okay so if it descended it would
ignite and eclipse everything with its light and with its heat but since all things created by me
contain the similarity with the bosom of mercy of its creator the sun remains where it is
emitting its rays full of goodness love and goods for the little earth now i want to give you a
couple of references for where we're going with this because if the sun actually came too close
it would just burn the whole earth up so i want to give you Hebrews 12 29 that is our god as a
consuming fire he's going to explain this in a moment and the very same thing is said in deuteronomy
424 and it's said in a slightly different way in aziah 33 14 who could dwell among the everlasting
burnings so because we go from the image of the sun to the divine will now if the sun does this
and it's only an image of the true light of the divine sun much more so does god the true sun
of light of justice and of love my majesty doesn't move from the height of its throne in other words
god reigns from his throne now if god comes to us in justice he comes too close to us we experience
him as a consuming fire that is the chastisement so notice what he's going to say now he's going to
allow people in the divine will to actually go up to him on behalf of everyone else so my majesty
does not move from the height of its throne but it's always firm and stable in its place in its
celestial royal palace more than the sun it emits its endless rays which carry its effects and its
goods and communicates its very life as if itself would descend to those who want to receive it so
everything is done from this great height so what it does not do by descending in person it does
through the emanation of its endless rays by locating in them to give its very life and it's good to
the human generations keep the image of the sun it's sending these rays to the earth and all the
good that comes to the earth is coming in these rays now these rays are very important because
we're going to be told at the end that the tips of those rays created the human will and that's why
we should be absolutely connected with the source now because of your condition as a creature he says
to louisa and because of your office that's concerning her office as the head of emission
of the supreme fiat it's your duty to go up on these rays that the supreme majesty emits
and to bring yourself before the supreme majesty and fulfill your office in the bosom of the eternal
sun plunging into the origin from which you came in order to take the fullness of my will as much
as it is possible for a creature and to know it and to manifest it to others in other words
louisa first and we after her have to become the eagles of god and if you examine the eagle
the eagle has special eyelids to protect it when it's flying into the sun so that it will still
be able to see and we are protected going into that divine presence to intercede for everybody
else but i love what he's saying here is that you're actually traveling on this ray
right to the very source of the ray and the extraordinary privilege that on behalf of a human
race in totally in rebellion against him that we're allowed to travel on that ray go into his presence
and intercede for them all absolutely magnificent so for the eagle i want to give you a proverbs 30
verses 18 and 19 three things i do not understand four indeed i don't understand and one of them is
the mystery of the eagle in the sky and the mystery of the eagle in the sky is in my opinion one of
the best images that we have of somebody in the divine will actually going right to the source
and bringing back life and grace and everything for people who desperately need it but won't thank
you because they don't understand and so it's just divine really so it's in the next paragraph
that tells us that the human will was made at the tips of these divine rays and therefore since the
human will was made we're meant to travel on those divine rays back into the source now you must know
that bonds of identification exist between the divine will and the human will identification
he's the sun we were made on the tips of the rays of that sun and therefore why i so much love
and want by right of creation paternity love and justice that the human will would surrender
its place to mine and throwing itself into the arms of the divine will like a little child that
sam one three one would let itself be held nourished and dominated by it now if the human will comes
out of the tips of the rays of the divine will its absolute right place is back on those rays
going back to the origin and that's where it experiences absolutely everything that god intended for
it this is very beautiful stuff so in creating man the supreme being placed my will out into the field
although all of our attributes concurred with it as a consequence and naturally because of this
extraordinary unity but the supreme volition was the primary act by which it took to heart the life
of all creation including man therefore making itself the life of all in other words we don't have
life outside of the divine will we have on life we have destruction we have deformity
we have disgrace but we don't have life so the divine will took to heart the life of all creation
including man and therefore making itself the life of all dominating everything making everything
its own since everything had come out of the divine will by justice everything was to be
its own it owned everything more than the song my will emitted its rays and with the tips of these
rays animating the human nature it formed the will of the creature now if you go to sam eight and
verse three you'll actually find that the ancient people actually knew this because they said lord
you created us by the tips of your fingers go back to sam eight it's actually very beautiful
so the divine will formed the will of the creature on the tips of these rays do you see therefore
what the will is in the human generations many different tips of rays which were like sparks in
the creature to form the will in them so each one of us is a little spark from god but without
detaching the sparks from the ray unleashed by the center of the sun of the supreme volition
so if each one of us is a tiny spark from one of those rays that spark cannot exist by itself
it cannot exist outside of its source and so it's only by going back on those rays right to the very
center that we find the fullness of life so all human generations turn around this sun because
each creature contains the tip of one ray of the eternal sun of the divine will might be something
you i'd like to write on a piece of paper just for yourself i am the tip of one ray of the divine will
it's a very beautiful thing so now what is not the affront for the sun to see the circumference
of these rays who's tipped formed the will of each creature converted transmuted into darkness
into human nature denying the light denying the dominion and the life of the sun which gave its
will with so much love so that the divine will and those creatures might be one and so that the
divine will might be able to form divine life in them we can't have the divine life without the
divine will can there be a stronger more stable more inseparable bond than the one between the
center of the sun and its rays now what he's explaining here is the sheer logic of us coming
into the divine will it just doesn't make sense to be outside of it so that it was intended in our
creation that we would have this bond of inseparability with the divine will light is indivisible and
god is light so one Timothy six sixteen god dwells in unapproachable light so light is indivisible
and if it could be separated the detached part would go wandering and would end up turning into
darkness that is exactly what happened to Lucifer he was an angel of light absolutely in union
with the divine light and he turned away from that and became darkness and all of us who turn away
from that divine light also become darkness so I want to give you Ezekiel 28 verses 12 to 19
and Isaiah 14 verses 12 to 15 which describe the fall of Lucifer and again they talk about you
were there in Eden you were the one who was so decorated by God you were so privileged by God
and now look at you it's incredible and so if you read those texts from Ezekiel and Isaiah
you get a better sense of what's being said here the sheer disaster of turning away from the light
so there is such union of identification between the divine will and the human
as to be comparable to the union that exists between the sun and the solar ray between the
heat and the light so he goes back to that image of the sun all the time that we know you cannot
separate a ray of light from the sun it cannot be done and you cannot separate the heat and the light
either they are completely inseparable and he says that was the way we were created that is our
origin we've got to go back to that inseparability and then all the light and the glory and the
grace and everything that God intended to come into us and through us and out to other people
will happen again and that's how the human race will recover and the more people who enter into
this relationship the more quickly the human race will recover from its present darkness
this is wonderful identification would it not be a right of the sun to dominate its rays
and to receive their subjections so as to form the kingdom of light over its solar circumference
so he's just using his own language there on the science of the sun and its rays
so it is for my will now what I'm going to read for you now I read it a number of times before I
realized what I was reading you know in all the writing we've had up to now that Louisa finds
the deprivation of Jesus completely intolerable well he's now going to tell us that we deprive
God and put him into a deprivation which is intolerable for him as well and it's only when I came to
this I said oh my now I begin to somehow grasp what is being said let's go back a tiny little bit
would it not be a right of the sun to dominate its rays and to receive their subjections to form
the kingdom of light okay so it's the same he said for my will when the creature withdraws from it
now this is the creature depriving God of his rights depriving God of his privileges he said
it remains as though without a kingdom without dominion without subjects the divine will feels
itself being robbed of that which is its own each act which does not depend on its volition
is a tearing a theft made against the light now look at the words that are being used which
describe deep pain a tearing a theft and in seeing itself being robbed of its light converted into
darkness it agonizes now if you take this and then go back and just read everything Louisa has
said about how terrifying is the pain she has in the deprivation of Jesus he is saying that the
divine will is caused this terrifying agony by us it's incredible the divine will agonizes more
than a mother who sees the fruit of her womb being snatched away from her not to give him life but
to kill him as an abortion so the losses that my will suffers when the creature is not united to
its center and does not live of the volition of its life our divine losses and of infinite value
therefore the pain is infinite the evils for creatures the ugliness that they acquire are
incalculable and indescribable and my will remains without a kingdom among the creatures and they
remain stripped of their inheritance with no right to any good whatsoever no just no right and you
hear that when we come back into the divine will and go back into that wonderful inseparable union
in the divine will that we regain our rights so outside of it they've no right to any good whatsoever
therefore there's nothing more important nothing greater which will establish the balance the order
of the harmony the likeness between the creator and the creature than my will this is why i want
to make known what the divine will is and what the human will is so that we may reconcile and that
my will may acquire its kingdom and the creatures may be given back all the goods that they have lost
now that particular message requires a lot of going over it slowly slowly slowly to take it in so
september the ninth 1926 when jesus speaks he actually gives what he says in other words go
back to genesis let there be light and there was light okay so louisa said i was thinking
this is obviously our thinking as well how much power how many goods are enclosed in the holy
divine will because we've just been told that all of these goods are going to flow out on anybody
who comes into that permanent union with him how everything is peace in the divine will and everything
is happiness nor does one need commands in order to operate okay but one's own nature feels so much
strength of good within itself that it cannot help doing it as she's describing what has happened
to her this utter transformation okay so i want to give you one krentians 13 13 that you know in
the end there's faith hope and love and the greatest of these is love want to give you Romans 13 8 to
10 as well so your whole being is transformed to the point that you actually want to do what god
wants what happiness she says to feel one's own nature converted into good into sanctity and into
strength so in the kingdom of the supreme will there will be no laws but everything will be love
one john four seven and following verse god is love and one's nature will be converted into
divine law in such a way that of its own it will want to do what the supreme fiat wants it to do
so Jeremiah 31 33 and 34 that the divine law will be written on our hearts and we will know
from within okay so she's saying that's going to be no laws that we will actually operate according
to the divine will so something that we would want to do would be what he wants to do as well
okay so watch this now there are steps in preparation so while i was thinking of this
beloved jesus with his usual light which he sent forth from his intelligence towards me
that's infused knowledge my daughter he said everything i've told you about my will has been
gifts that i've given to you knowledge is not enough you need to underline that about 10 times
because we're studying the volumes and it's very important to study the volumes but if you leave
this as simply information in your head and you're not allowing it to enter into your inner
most being to transform you it's a waste of time and if you're judged according to your
knowledge in the end you might be in trouble so knowledge isn't enough if one does not possess
the good which that very knowledge contains so the whole idea is that you come to know
what the lord is revealing you reach out for it and you receive it you take it into yourself
let it transform you it becomes part of your history so that's the way they sing actually works
so knowledge isn't enough if one doesn't possess the good that the knowledge contains
if it were not so the knowledge would render you unhappy because we'll be telling you about
wonderful things you couldn't have because knowing a good and not possessing it is always a sorrow
more so since i do not know how to leave things halved on but only things that are fully and complete
so watch this therefore number one i disposed the soul now again this is for your discernment
for yourself what's going on inside of you number one i disposed the soul number two i expand her
capacity in other words we start out small but if we live the bit we know he expands to him who
has more will be given until they have more than they have enough okay so the second thing is i
expand her capacity and number three i give the knowledge together with the good it contains
that's what he wants is that as we come into this knowledge we actually take it and we take
possession of it and it becomes us it doesn't become ours it becomes us it's actually transformed into
us and since the knowledge of my will is divine this is why her nature remains endowed with the
likeness of the divine nature so we become more and more and more like god and more than a daughter
she does not wait for a command but without being told feels honored to do what her father does
okay it's a very famous statement of saint Augustine which is gravely misunderstood
it is love god and do what you like so it seems to people who at a very low level of spirituality
that if you give god any attention then you know it's free for all it's not that
is that if you enter into this relationship with god what you want to do is what he wants to do
because there's only one will between the two of you and there's only one love there isn't a
worldly love mixed with the divine love there isn't a selfish love mixed with the divine love there's
only one will and only one love and therefore what you do is what he wants you to do so he goes on to
tell us this is the position that there was in the Old Testament that laws and commands are for
servants for slaves and for rebels in other words try and put some order into a community in the
kingdom of the supreme fiat there are no servants there are no slaves and there are no rebels
there's only one will okay now if you're at the stage of laws and commands you're in Romans 7
where Paul says I do the things I don't want to do and I don't do the things I should do
so that's the struggle of someone not come into this extraordinary unity okay I also have here
Romans 4 verses 13 to 17 so in the divine will there's only one will and that one will is the
combination of God and of the creature the two wills are one one is completely surrendered to the
other so this is the reason why I'm saying so much and so many things about my will to abound in gifts
not only for you but for any soul that includes you and me who wants to come and live in my kingdom
he wants to pour out gifts in abundance upon us all so that she may lack nothing for time or
eternity she may need nothing but possess the source of goods within herself now those of you
who are studying the book of numbers with me are looking at the very sad situation where the people
of God are just not able to come around and trust God to provide everything for them he wants to
give them everything he wants everything to be gift for them and no no they they want something
else and so we can destroy this simply because we might want something else but the more we
surrender our will to the divine will it's totally liberating I mean it's totally freeing it's
incredible and you can't help being happy because there's no struggle inside of you so he said I
would not act as the God that I am great powerful rich and magnanimous if in having to
constitute the kingdom of my will I did not endow those who live in it with the prerogatives and
qualities that my very will possesses even more you must know that just as all things have come
out of that single act of God that singularity so almost everything returned to that single act
which is no succession of acts yeah you've heard me say this in different ways on this journey
and that is everything came out of this incredible generous love of God giving life to the angels
giving life to humanity giving life but he wants intelligent beings to come back to him by their own
will he doesn't want slaves he doesn't want robots thank you human beings seem to want robots but he
doesn't he wants someone to come back of their own will just think of the joy you have if a small
child comes to you even though they have plucked your favorite rose from the garden and it hasn't
been plucked properly and hands it to you and says mommy I love you or granny I love you or daddy I
love you it's the spontaneous love of that child that is the supreme gift the rose is merely a symbol
of it it's the fact that the child taught of you and wanted to make this thing it's the child's will
and it is abounding in love coming back to you that's what the lord wants and I keep saying to you
that all of these mysteries are hidden in the tabernacle of the family they're hidden in the
relationships of the spouses and their spouses and their children and the children and the children
to the spouses it's all hidden there all of these mysteries it's absolutely fantastic and if we could
get our eyes opened to see in the little things that happen to us that there's something much much
greater actually being revealed to you and so the lord wants each one of us his little children
to come back to him spontaneously with the I love you that's what he's asking of us and that's what
a child will do spontaneously for the parent or the grandparent only one who leaves everything to live
of my will can return to that single act in other words you can't bring any baggage with you there
isn't any room the only thing we can take with us back to god is love because god is love so if we
want to bring something of me something of the world something of the material thing sorry you're
not getting there you won't get there so they have to leave everything so deuteronomy six verses four
to ten here always rail the lord your god is one lord and you shall love the lord your god with all
your heart that's not ninety nine percent all your soul all your mind and all your being that's what
the lord wants all or nothing so only somebody who leaves everything can return to that single act
because as the soul lives in the divine will everything she does converts to light and that
material thing you're holding on to it won't convert to light that stupid opinion that you're
sticking on to won't convert to light that silly selfishness won't convert to light
and her acts are naturally incorporated and identified with the eternal light of the sun
of the divine will and as a consequence they become one single act with the single act of the divine
will but it has to be all completely spiritual the material is out that's to be all completely
spiritual on the other hand in one who operates outside of the divine will one can see not light
but each of the materials that her work contains which cannot be incorporated into the light or
in the single act of god and therefore it will show immediately that it's not ours
not our thing and it does not belong to us so anything which is not done by virtue of the divine
fear will not be recognized by god it's actually that simple he only wants his own things in his own
kingdom so he's going to give an explanation of that now in the next paragraph suppose you
wanted to unite light and darkness copper and gold rocks and earth but he's giving him possible
serenity would one not distinguish with clarity the light from the darkness the copper from the
gold and the rocks from the earth and this because these are materials very different from each other
but if you united altogether light with light darkness with darkness gold with gold you would
not be able to distinguish nor separate the first from the second the first darkness from the second
one the first mass of gold from the second so it is my will what is itself does in the creature
is light and converts everything into light and it's no wonder therefore that it becomes
incorporated into that single act of the eternal light therefore in these times so stormy with a
vertiginous race to evil vertiginous means a dizzy race to evil i could not give a greater
grace than making known that i want to give the great gift of the kingdom of the supreme fear
now one of the things that the scriptures make very clear and that is that in the worst of times
god gives the greatest of gifts that's the amazing thing and that's what he's doing now as well
and as a confirmation of this i am preparing the divine will within you with so much knowledge and
gifts so that nothing may be lacking to the triumph of my will therefore be attentive
on the deposit of this kingdom that i am making in you so after this louisa said that she felt
concerned about holy obedience because it had imposed on her not neglect even one word this is a
very interesting passage and it's completely different from what we've just read it's completely
different message altogether so she had received an obedience not an neglect even one word of that
which jesus was saying to her and she said i easily leave them out now she's admitted that
all throughout the volumes that she leaves things out because i'm convinced it's not necessary to
write and to entrust a paper certain intimate things certain outpourings that jesus makes to
my poor soul but that they should remain in the depths of the heart so i was praying that he would
give me the grace not to fail the obedience and jesus moving in my interior gave her a new understanding
of obedience which i think is absolutely fantastic he said my daughter if the one who guides you who
is a priest your spiritual director directs and directs you gives you this obedience it means that
he has understood that it is i who speaks to you this is a major advance that jesus is saying the
priests who are guiding louise have had long last it only took 19 volumes had long last realized it
really is jesus this is a supernatural thing this is a mighty step forward very important
so they've understood that it is i who speaks to you as well they've also understood the value of
even a single word of mine of course if it's the lord's word every single word is extremely
important my word is light and is full of life and the one who possesses it can give this life
and this light more so since my word contains the creative now the word use there is strength i
don't think that's use in english i think we have to say my word contains the creative power and
therefore a single word of mine can create innumerable lives in grace you see to create you need power
and it is the creative power okay so it can create innumerable lives of grace love lives of light
lives of my will within souls notice even one word you yourself will not be able to understand
the long way that a single word of mine can cover sometimes it's just one sentence or one little
phrase or one little thing that makes all the difference in a person's life that that is the
turning point that's what he's saying those who have ears will listen that's matthew 11 15
and mark four nine those who have ears will listen those who have heart will be touched is what we
say in english wounded is not the language we use we use the word wounded for something else
so the one who guides you is right in giving you this obedience ah you do not know how i assist
him i remain around him and while he reads my writings and yours well my will so as to make
him understand all the power of the truths and the great good contained in them now look at what
jesus is saying to get this priest to understand and grasp the importance of what he's reading
jesus says i'm around him i'm helping him i'm enlightening him and he's doing the same with us
as well when we come to read and try and understand the writings he is with us because he's more
anxious for us to understand than maybe we are ourselves and he continues he turns around my will
and by virtue of the light that he feels he is sending you this obedience therefore be attentive
and i will help you and facilitate that which is difficult for you so jesus continues you must
know that my heart is swollen it agonizes and its size because i want to make known the kingdom
of the supreme fiat the great goods which are in it and the great good which those who will possess
it will receive it is precisely in my heart that i keep it this is a matter of the sacred heart of
jesus and i feel my heart explode but i want to let it out so we just can't comprehend the
infinite love that is actually involved don't you want then to give me this relief so that by letting
it out my heart may deflate in other words not explode and so it will not have to agonize and
sigh with sorrowful size anymore and you will do this by making it known now notice how we can
console the heart of jesus by making this material known to others and i manifest to you about my
will because when you do this you give me the field in order to open the ways and prepare the place
in which i must lay the kingdom of my will in other words we don't know who's going to respond
to this it's our duty to get this information out and the mystery that will go on between god
and the soul will take over but if you don't manifest what i say to you you close the ways and my
heart swells even more therefore let me do follow me and don't be concerned so there's an awful lot
in what we have shared tonight you need to take it nice and slowly piece by piece so thank you for
joining us and god bless